le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
même si on a de bons résultats scolaires
cela n'aboutit pas systématiquement vers
une embauche c'est pour cela que
l'apprentissage est une voie d'insertion
intéressante car elle allie pratique et
théorie soutenir l'apprentissage comme
levier d'insertion durable dans la vie
professionnelle
telle est l'ambition du conseil général
il est d'ailleurs le premier employeurs
d'apprentis de lille en accueillant des
apprentis venus de divers horizons et de
diverses formations pour découvrir les
différents métiers du conseil général
qu'est-ce que l'apprentissage qui peut
être apprenti on en parle tout de suite
d'un lien social
le conseil général permet aux jeunes
réunionnais de se confronter très
rapidement à la réalité professionnelle
une réalité parfois bien différente du
cursus scolaire l'apprentissage est une
formation en alternance formalisé dans
le cadre d'un contrat d'apprentissage
le contrat d'apprentissage est un
contrat de travail à durée déterminée
signé entre le jeune de 16 à 25 ans est
la structure d'accueil pour une durée de
six mois à trois ans selon le diplôme
préparé il est donc rémunéré par
l'employeur qui s'engage à lui assurer
une formation professionnelle complète
dispensés pour partie en entreprise et
pour partie en centre de formation cfa
ou en section d'apprentissage
magali à maille a choisi une activité
qui la passionne celle de l'aménagement
paysager
je prépare un bts en aménagement
cfa agricole de saint paul j'ai la
chance votre apprenti à l'interruption
de l'environnement au conseil général
nos missions dans notre travail consiste
à travailler sur l'aménagement la
valorisation des espaces naturels pour
l'accueil des publics
tels que les partis mais sentiers la
signalétique si je choisis partie sur
cette formation c
et pour une certaine passion et
beaucoup d'amour pour les forêts je suis
très sensible à la place
une vie végétale des plantes des arbres
dans notre milieu de vie et j'ai un
parcours particulier je suis diplômée en
arts appliqués
par la suite je n'ai pas continué mes
études et j'ai commencé à travailler
chez travaillante un super deluxe et
ma passion pour la nature et les
nombreuses en donner j'ai eu la chance
de faire sur notre magnifique il m'a
amené à proposer ma candidature
afin de faire toute ma période
d'apprentissage au conseil général
en charge de l'aménagement des espaces
naturels le bts aménagement paysager se
fait sur une base de formation en
alternance donc
sur l'apprentissage le plus c'est
d'apprendre tout ce qui est technique
théorique à l'école et mettre tout ça en
pratique en entreprise qui permet de
découvrir le côté concret et réel du
médecin aujourd'hui nous sommes sur le
départ du chemin des anglais et côté
saint bernard nous sommes venus faire
les premières analyses de paysage pour
l'aménagement de parkings afin
d'embellir le lieu et le rendre beaucoup
plus fonctionnel à l'accueil du public
par ailleurs il est quand même important
de noter
que nous souffrons sur un milieu
de forêt celui sèche et que ce type de
végétaux est malheureusement en voie de
disparition et qu'il faut absolument
faire une restauration magali a pu être
soutenu par son maître d'apprentissage
christian bay vers moi j'ai été formés
professionnellement en grande partie par
le conseil général aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance de pouvoir restituer redonner
quelque part que savoir que j'ai pu
acquérir
pour un jeune un apprenti et lui
permettent de démarrer sa vie
professionnelle je dirais
progressivement par alternance
l'internât les cours et les la mise en
pratique je pense que c'est une bonne
méthode qui permet ensuite de s'intégrer
plus facilement sur le marché du travail
puisque le l'apprenti finalement on va
pratiquer bien sûr mais va se faire
également un réseau va rencontrer du
monde dans tout le tous les partenaires
qui s'occupe des espaces naturels c'est
un partenariat gagnant gagnant puisque
on a un vrai besoin aussi en termes de
ressources humaines puisque les attentes
les besoins sur les espaces naturels
sont grands une reconnaissance nationale
internationale et patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et donc on a besoin d'avoir un
accueil du public puisque c'est notre
spécialité qui soit vraiment de qualité
et pour qu'ils soient de qualité il faut
qu on ait des sites notamment des portes
d'entrée de sites qu'ils soient qui soit
belle et donc avoir la chance d'avoir
une paysagiste
qui fait de l'aménagement dans notre
service c'est une vraie sans sa va
apporter de compétences opérationnelles
quelqu'un qui est capable de dessiner de
concevoir des aménagements et ensuite de
les mettre en pratique directement ou
via des entreprises pour apporter
vraiment un côté qualitatif à noam
énergie malgré des contraintes
budgétaires croissantes le conseil
général cette année a atteint son
objectif de 100 nouveaux apprentis avec
47 diplômes différents dans la
collectivité au total avec ceux qui
réalisent leur deuxième année le
département accueille environ 200
apprentis en ses murs l'apprentissage
est aussi un moyen de faire connaître
les différents métiers de la fonction
publique territoriale à ses apprentis
et pour que cette jeunesse trouve la
confiance en l'avenir et l'envi de se
battre pour sa réussite
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais